From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Sean Cole in for Ira Glass. The first punch landed on sort of the lower back right side of my skull, behind my ear. That was the one that knocked me down.
这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ的《美国生活》节目。我是肖恩·科尔，代替艾拉·格拉斯主持。第一拳打在了我头骨右后下方，耳朵后面。那一拳把我打倒在地。
This was a couple summers ago. I'd been walking down this sort of abandoned industrial block in my neighborhood in Brooklyn. It was after midnight. There was a big group of kids-- teenagers, boys-- maybe 9 or 10 of them, coming the other way. I was on the sidewalk. They were walking in the middle of the street, where the cars go. Also, I was on the phone with my friend, Sam, talking to him with my earbuds in.
那是几个夏天前的事了。当时我正走在布鲁克林家附近一条废弃的工业街区，时间已经过了午夜。迎面走来一大群孩子——都是十几岁的男孩，大概有9到10个。我在人行道上，他们走在汽车通行的马路中间。当时我还戴着耳塞，正和我的朋友萨姆通电话。
So I just kept walking and talking, glancing over at the kids a couple of times. And then I saw them see me. And they sort of stopped and said something to each other. And then a few of them, casually-- like I wouldn't notice-- started walking in my direction. I don't know if taking off in a sprint was the best decision, or if you could even call it a decision.
于是我继续走着，聊着天，偶尔瞥那群孩子几眼。后来我看到他们发现了我，他们停下脚步，互相说了些什么。紧接着，其中几个看起来很随意——好像我不会注意到似的——开始朝我的方向走来。我不知道当时跑起来是不是最好的决定，甚至不知道那能不能算是个决定。
A couple of the kids said, yeah! There are a few things I remember about the next 30 seconds or so and a few things I don't. I remember looking down at my shoes and thinking, why can't I run any faster than this?
其中几个孩子喊道：“耶！”关于接下来的那30秒左右，我记得一些事，也有一些事我不记得了。我记得当时低头看着自己的鞋子，心想：我怎么就跑不快呢？
Sam said, what's happening? I said, I'm being chased. Who's chasing you, he said. They're chasing me, I apparently said, which I don't remember. I don't remember how I got off the ground after the first punch. I just know that a second later, I was running again and still getting punched in the head. Being punched in the head while running becomes withstandable remarkably quickly. After the second hit, my skull was like, if this is all that's going to happen, you can manage. One kid way in the back, nowhere near me, yelled, give me your wallet, but laughing, like it was a joke. They never tried to take anything. They easily could have.
萨姆问：“怎么了？”我说：“我被人追赶。”他说：“谁在追你？”我脱口而出：“他们在追我。”但我对此毫无印象。我不记得第一拳被打倒后是怎么爬起来的，我只知道一秒钟后，我又跑了起来，头上还在挨拳头。在奔跑的同时被击打头部，适应起来快得惊人。第二次被击中后，我的头骨好像在说：如果这已经是全部，那你还能应付。最后面有个孩子，离我挺远，喊了一句：“把钱包给我”，但语气带着笑意，像是在开玩笑。他们从未试图抢走任何东西，明明他们很容易就能做到。
I've tried to come up with something to compare the experience of it to, but I've never felt anything else that intensely. I've never felt as good in my life as how bad that was. I rounded the corner and saw a semi truck coming. It was the only moving vehicle around. I ran toward it with my arms straight up over my head. And when I looked back, the kids had vanished-- gone just like they'd never been there in the first place. I slowed to a walk, which is when I noticed my earbuds were neatly spooled around my left ankle, like I'd done it on purpose. One of them was smashed. And when I lifted the other one up toward my face--
我试着找些东西来比拟这种体验，但我从未有过如此强烈的感受。我这辈子从未像那一刻那样感觉糟糕到极致。我拐过街角，看到一辆半挂车驶来，那是周围唯一的移动车辆。我双臂高举过头顶向它跑去。等我回头看时，那群孩子已经消失了——就像他们从未出现过一样。我慢下脚步，这时我才注意到耳塞整齐地缠绕在我的左脚踝上，就像我是故意那样做的一样。其中一个耳塞已经碎了，当我把另一个举到脸前时——
Sean, are you OK? Sean. Sean. Sean, talk to me.
肖恩，你还好吗？肖恩。肖恩。肖恩，跟我说话。
Sam was still on the phone.
萨姆还在电话那头。
Sean. Sean?
肖恩。肖恩？
Yeah, I'm OK.
嗯，我没事。
Are you OK? What's up? What happened?
你还好吗？怎么了？发生了什么？
I'm OK. I'm OK. I-- there was a gang of guys.
我没事。我没事。我……有一群人。
Sean, I'm recording this call--
肖恩，我正在录这段通话——
Can you hear me?
你能听见我说话吗？
So tell me what happened. I'm recording the call.
告诉我发生了什么。我正在录音。
This recording is the whole reason I'm telling you about this. When he realized something was wrong, Sam had taken the phone away from his ear and opened up this recording app, in case I needed some kind of evidence or something later. He's extremely organized that way. And I'm really glad he did it. For one thing, I have this bizarrely candid portrait of myself now, in the moment exactly after one of the worst things that's ever happened to me. It took a while for me to be able to listen to it.
这段录音就是我告诉你们这件事的原因。当萨姆意识到出事时，他把手机从耳边拿开，打开了录音软件，以防我以后需要什么证据之类的。他在这方面非常有条理，我真的很庆幸他这么做了。一方面，我现在有了自己遭遇人生中最糟糕事件之后那一刻极其坦诚的肖像。我花了好一阵子才敢去听这段录音。
But I mean, there was a lot of them. There was like a lot of guys.
我是说，他们人很多。大概有很多家伙。
I'm used to hearing my voice recorded and controlling the way I sound, like the way I'm talking to you right now.
我习惯了听自己的录音，并控制说话的声音，就像我现在跟你说话这样。
Do you want to--
你想要——
There were a lot of guys.
那儿有很多家伙。
But this was like some unbidden child creature, bubbling up from my throat. When I listen to it, it's like I've finally taken some mask off that I didn't know I was wearing.
但这听起来像是一个不请自来的儿童生物，从我的喉咙里冒出来。当我听它的时候，感觉就像我终于摘下了一个我之前都没意识到自己戴着的面具。
And they kept hitting me on the head, and then I fell. And I scraped myself up a bit, but I'm OK. They didn't get anything.
他们一直打我的头，然后我摔倒了。我擦伤了一点，但我没事。他们没拿走任何东西。
What did they hit you with?
他们用什么打你？
I think just their hands.
我想只是他们的手。
Oh god.
哦，天哪。
God, that was scary. Jesus fucking Christ, that was scary.
天啊，那太吓人了。妈的，简直吓死人了。
But you're all right?
但你还好吗？
Jesus. No, I'm fine. I'm OK.
天哪。不，我很好。我没事。
Take some deep breaths, Sean. You're really going to hyperventilate.
做个深呼吸，肖恩。你快要过度换气了。
No, I'm actually fine. Like, I--
不，我真的没事。我是说，我——
And this is another thing-- this kind of incantation I keep repeating of, I'm fine, I'm fine. Instead of telling Sam what did happen, I spend most of the call focusing on how bad it could have been. It's like I'm clinging to a buoy in the ocean after a shipwreck.
还有一件事——我一直像念咒语一样重复说“我没事，我没事”。我没有告诉萨姆到底发生了什么，而是大部分通话时间都在强调这事儿本来可能会有多糟糕。就像海难后我紧紧抓住海面上的浮标一样。
It could have been a lot worse.
本来可能更糟糕的。
Jesus.
天哪。
It could have been a lot worse. I lost my glasses.
本来可能更糟糕的。我把眼镜弄丢了。
Oh no.
哦，不。
But it's OK. I mean, I'm fine. I'm OK. I'm OK. It could have been way worse. I'm actually fine. I'm actually fine.
但没关系。我是说，我很好。我没事。我没事。本来可能更糟糕的。我真的没事。我真的没事。
I never say things could be worse. Almost every other time in my life has been better than this one. And yet most of the time, I just brood about what's going wrong or what I wish I'd done differently. But here, I was clearly just paving over all the broken glass of what happened to me immediately, counting my blessings in a way I'm never usually able to. And of course, it could have been way worse. Truly catastrophic things happen to people all over the world every day.
我从不说“本来可能更糟糕”这种话。我生命中几乎每一个其他时刻都比这一刻好。然而大多数时候，我只是苦思冥想哪里出了问题，或者希望自己能有不同的做法。但在这里，我显然是在掩盖自己遭遇的所有创伤碎片，以一种我通常无法做到的方式数算着自己的恩典。当然，本来可能会糟糕得多。世界各地每天都在发生真正灾难性的事情。
I remember talking to Sam for 45 minutes. It was actually about 12 minutes, which I couldn't believe. I was like, where's the rest of it?
我记得跟萨姆聊了45分钟。实际上大概只有12分钟，我简直不敢相信。我当时想，剩下那些哪去了？
By minute six, six minutes after the attack, we're already starting to laugh about stuff. I told him that I had been heading down to my car to get a pack of cigarettes. And he says, yeah, well, I guess it'll kill you. It's good to know we were able to talk about it like that so quickly. It makes a lot of bad things seem more survivable.
到了第六分钟，也就是袭击发生六分钟后，我们已经开始拿这件事开玩笑了。我告诉他，我本来要去车里拿包香烟。他说：“是啊，好吧，我猜那烟会杀了你。”很高兴知道我们能这么快就以这种方式谈论它。这让很多糟糕的事情看起来更容易承受了。
We spend so much time trying to control how we're seen by other people. But sometimes we can catch an unexpected glimpse of ourselves that we haven't manicured and that has way more information in it about how we actually are. It might not be the funnest thing to witness, but at least we know. In today's show, we got two stories in which that happens-- two different people seeing themselves in the wild and what it confirms, or doesn't, about who they think they are. Stay with us.
我们花太多时间试图控制自己在别人眼中的形象。但有时我们可以捕捉到自己意想不到的一面，那些未加修饰、包含了我们真实状态信息的自我。 witness 它可能不是最愉快的，但至少我们了解了。在今天的节目里，我们有两个故事发生过类似的情况——两个人以一种野生的方式看到了自己，这证实了或者否定了他们对自己身份的认知。请继续收听。
Jesus. And that was something. That'll wake you up, won't it? Jesus.
天哪。那真是……那会让你清醒过来，对吧？天哪。
Act I. You don't have to be a star to be in my show. I want to tell you about my friend Zack's first big break-- Zack McDermott. We're pretty different people. Zack's from Wichita, and he has this kind of macho Kansan self certainty about him on the surface. I do an impression of him that I finally broke out when we were hanging with each other a couple of months ago.
第一幕。你不必成为明星也能出现在我的秀里。我想告诉你关于我朋友扎克·麦克德莫特的第一次重大突破。我们是非常不同的人。扎克来自威奇托，他表面上有一种堪萨斯男子汉式的自我笃定。几个月前我们聚在一起时，我模仿了他的样子，他对此深表赞同。
You know, I'm a writer. I wasn't able to get gussied up for you. I wasn't expecting you to be looking at my hair like that.
你知道，我是一个作家。我没能为你打扮得光鲜亮丽。我没想到你会盯着我的头发看。
That was pretty good. That flatters me a great deal.
那模仿得真不错。这让我非常受宠若惊。
Why?
为什么？
I don't think you usually do impressions of people, unless you kind of really like them or don't like them at all.
我不认为你通常会模仿别人，除非你真的很喜欢他们，或者根本不喜欢他们。
Or if you super don't like them.
或者你超级不喜欢他们。
Right.
对。
Yeah.
是啊。
And I feel like you more super like me than super don't.
我觉得你更倾向于超级喜欢我，而不是超级不喜欢。
I super like you.
我超级喜欢你。
Zack is this singular combination of things I really haven't encountered before. As well as being swaggery, he can also be awkward and vulnerable. He's conspicuously caring for the people he cares about. After my assault, he made me promise I'd call him in the middle of the night if I needed to.
扎克是我从未遇到过的一种独特的结合体。除了傲慢之外，他也可以表现得笨拙且脆弱。他明显地关心他所爱的人。在我遇袭后，他让我保证如果需要的话，半夜也要给他打电话。
He spent about seven years working as a public defender for the Legal Aid Society of New York, sometimes juggling more than 60 cases, righteously indignant about the court system. He's always giving advice, but he also needs to be reassured a lot. And he really likes other people's attention. He's always watching himself, in ways both literal and not, which, anyway, brings me to the story of the big break.
他曾作为纽约法律援助协会的公设辩护律师工作了大约七年，有时同时处理60多起案件，对司法系统义愤填膺。他总是给别人建议，但也需要别人给他很多心理安慰。他真的很喜欢别人的关注。他总是以各种方式注视着自己，无论是字面意义还是其他意义，无论如何，这让我想到了他那个重大突破的故事。
See, about 10 years ago, when he was still a public defender, Zack was also trying to make it as a comedian, grinding away, sometimes doing four or five open mics a night. His act was pretty intense back then. He had a mohawk, and Frank Zappa mustache, and jazz patch. One time, he came out onstage, just shouting lyrics from the rapper, Gucci Mane.
大约10年前，当他还是公设辩护律师时，扎克也试图成为一名喜剧演员，努力打拼，有时一晚要参加四五场公开麦。那时他的表演非常狂野。他留着莫霍克发型，蓄着弗兰克·扎帕式的小胡子，还有爵士补丁。有一次，他上台时只是在大声念唱说唱歌手Gucci Mane的歌词。
[RAPPING]
[说唱音乐]
He'd usually record his set, just with a little video camera or phone. And he also had this friend who was always egging him on, sort of repping him in a way. Zack always refers to him just as the producer. He doesn't want me to say who the guy is, but he's famous adjacent-- ran with a really heavy crowd. And apparently, he had big dreams for Zack's future.
他通常会录下他的演出，就用小型摄像机或手机。他还有个朋友一直在怂恿他，某种程度上算是他的经纪人。扎克总是只称呼他为“制作人”。他不想让我说出那是谁，但他和名人圈子挨得很近——混迹于一个非常强势的群体。显然，他对比扎克的未来有着宏大的梦想。
It was like, oh, yeah, don't worry. I know Hova. Don't worry, I know Jimmy Fallon. Don't worry, I know--
就像，哦，是的，别担心。我认识Hova（Jay-Z）。别担心，我认识吉米·法伦。别担心，我认识——
Hova is Jay-Z.
Hova就是Jay-Z。
Yeah. You know? Meeting all these people with him and him telling me, like, you're my project, man. I'm putting everything behind you. I'm willing to put all my money behind you. I'm willing to put all my connects behind you. You're next, you know? Trust me. When I push the button, it's going to go fast.
是啊，你知道吗？和他见了很多人，他告诉我就像，“你是我的项目，伙计。我把一切都押在你身上。我愿意把所有的钱都投在你身上。我愿意动用我所有的关系。下一个红的就是你，你知道吗？相信我。当我按下按钮时，一切都会飞速发展。”
They worked on a pilot for a TV show together, held a casting call for the role of Zack's girlfriend, collected headshots, did screen tests-- the whole thing. And then, in the fall of 2009, Zack found himself walking out of his apartment building and onto the set of a TV pilot in which he was the star.
他们一起制作了一个电视节目的试播集，为扎克女朋友的角色进行了选角，收集了头像，进行了试镜——全套流程。然后，在2009年的秋天，扎克发现自己走出公寓大楼，走进了他作为明星主演的一部电视试播集的片场。
Everything just looked perfect, like a Coke commercial. It was a gorgeous day. It was a fall day in New York-- sunny. There was a realistic amount of people on the street, but not so many that the scene is going to look like rush hour. Because it wasn't. It was the middle of the day. It should look like the middle of the day. And everyone is also just a little too attractive.
一切看起来都很完美，就像可口可乐的广告。那是美好的一天。纽约的一个秋日——阳光明媚。街上的人流适中，不会多到让场景看起来像高峰时段。因为并不是高峰期。那是在中午。看起来就应该是中午的样子。每个人看起来也都有点太有吸引力了。
Like actors.
就像演员一样。
Everyone.
每个人都是。
I don't have audio of this because it was never actually recorded. Because it wasn't a TV pilot. Those people on the street weren't actors. This wasn't Zack's first big break into show business. It was his first big psychotic break, like the part of his brain that wanted to be in the spotlight all the time had suddenly exploded.
我没有这段音频，因为实际上根本没有被录下来。因为那不是什么电视试播集。街上的那些人不是演员。这也不是扎克在演艺圈的第一次重大突破。这是他第一次严重的精神崩溃，就像他大脑里那个一直渴望成为焦点的一部分突然爆炸了。
Zack was experiencing a type of delusion that we've talked about a little bit on the show before. It's called the Truman Show delusion-- not incredibly common, but not as rare as you might think either. Sufferers of Truman Show delusion basically think they're being filmed all the time by hidden cameras, just like the Jim Carrey character in the movie The Truman Show.
扎克经历的是一种我们节目之前提到过的妄想。它被称为“楚门秀妄想”——虽然不太普遍，但也没有你想象的那么罕见。楚门秀妄想的患者基本认为他们一直被隐藏的摄像机拍摄，就像电影《楚门秀》里的金·凯瑞角色一样。
In the weeks leading up to the break, Zack had been showing signs of this oncoming split with reality-- little harbingers and then bigger ones. He'd been growing more and more manic, sleeping less and less.
在崩溃前的几周，扎克已经表现出这种与现实分裂的迹象——一些小预兆，然后是更大的预兆。他变得越来越狂躁，睡眠越来越少。
I had some friends and family start to be concerned about me. And I kind of just brushed it all off. You don't understand what's going on in my brain. You don't understand how to write comedy. You don't understand how to do comedy. You don't understand how to do comedy after you're a lawyer all day.
我的一些朋友和家人开始为我担心。我基本上都把他们打发了。你们不明白我的大脑里在发生什么。你们不明白怎么写喜剧。你们不明白怎么做喜剧。你们不明白在做了一整天律师后怎么做喜剧。
You don't understand how to write a joke. Look, it's a mathematical equation. Let me show you. This is a premise. This is why this is funny. This is why that's not funny.
你不明白怎么写笑话。看，这是一个数学公式。让我展示给你看。这是前提。这就是为什么这个好笑。这就是为什么那个不好笑。
That's your inner monologue.
那是你的内心独白。
You don't understand-- and outer monologue.
你不明白——还有外在独白。
Even the producer was concerned. He told Zack he had to go see a doctor if they were going to keep working together. And yet, when Zack walked out of his apartment building onto the street that day, he was sure the producer had staged everything just for him. And Zack was ready to perform, thinking of himself as some hybrid of Ali G and Johnny Knoxville.
甚至那位制作人也很担心。他告诉扎克，如果他们还要继续合作，他就必须去看医生。然而，当那天扎克走出公寓楼来到街上时，他确信制作人已经为他安排好了一切。扎克准备好表演了，把自己想象成阿里·G和强尼·诺克斯维尔的结合体。
I'm thinking my friend, the brilliant producer, had decided, you know what? Zack's not really an actor. He's not going to know how to act. I'm just going to throw him in somewhere. He'll eventually get what he's supposed to be doing and he'll just kind of like, basically method act himself. He could probably do that. You know? So, I go to Tompkins Square Park. Soon as I'm in there, I spot generic old man on park bench.
我以为我的朋友，那位天才制作人决定，你知道吗？扎克不是真正的演员。他不知道怎么演。我就把他随便丢进某个地方。他最终会明白他该做什么，他会进行沉浸式表演。他或许能做到。你知道吗？所以我去了汤普金斯广场公园。一进公园，我就发现了长椅上的典型老头。
That's what it would say if he was in the credits.
如果他在演职员表里，那就是这么写的。
Yes, and he had a bike. And he was too old to have a bike.
是的，他还有一辆自行车。他太老了，不该骑自行车。
Another tell that the entire neighborhood had been cordoned off to showcase Zack's comedic talents. Zack thought it would be funny if he grabbed generic old man's bike and did a couple laps around the park with it. Generic old man did not take kindly to Zack trying to grab his bike away. Zack relented. It was surely a sign from the producer. Keep things moving. So Zack takes off in a sprint toward the middle of the park and vaults over the wall of this big doggy playpen.
这是整个街区被戒严以展示扎克喜剧天赋的另一个暗示。扎克觉得如果他抢走那个老头的自行车，在公园里骑上两圈会很有趣。典型老头并不乐意扎克抢他的自行车。扎克放弃了。这肯定来自制作人的暗示。继续前进。于是扎克朝着公园中间冲刺，越过了狗乐园的围栏。
I get down, like, on all fours myself. And I gallop with the pack. Running toward the end of the fence, I jump out the other side. And I'm like, all right, cool. Whatever that was worth, I did it. You know?
我自己趴在地上。我和这群狗一起奔跑。跑向围栏尽头时，我跳到了另一边。我心想，好极了，不管这值不值得，反正我做到了。你知道吗？
That was funny, maybe.
那或许很有趣。
Yeah, that was funny maybe. Who knows? And I also was thinking that the pedestrians were extras, doubling as production assistants. And I'm supposed to follow them, follow the foot traffic that will take you where you need to go. No one's coming up to me with a clipboard and a shot list or anything, right?
是的，或许有趣。谁知道呢？我还以为行人们是群众演员，同时也兼任制作助理。我应该跟随他们，跟着人流走，他们会带我去我该去的地方。没有人带着剪贴板和拍摄清单来找我，对吧？
So they're then phoning ahead to the producer or whatever production unit, saying, OK, he's on First Avenue. He's almost to Houston. And like, OK, we'll make him go west then.
所以他们会提前打电话给制作人或制作单位，说：“好了，他在第一大道。快到休斯顿街了。”然后就说：“好吧，那我们就让他往西走。”
Whenever Zack tells this story, he has a whole menu of deranged things he did that day to talk about-- running around the soccer field with his shorts pulled down while a game is going on, ordering champagne on a hotel patio and proceeding to yell at the cameras in the trees. As Zack remembers it-- and Zack's memory is all we have to go on-- this television non-debut lasted for about 10 hours-- a 10 hour narcissism variety show arranged for him to give the performance of his life.
每当扎克讲起这个故事，他总有一整套在那天做的疯狂事迹可说——把裤子脱了在足球场周围乱跑，在酒店露台上点香槟，然后对着树里的摄像机大喊大叫。正如扎克所记忆的那样——而扎克的记忆是我们唯一能依靠的东西——这场电视非首秀持续了大约10个小时——一场为他安排的10小时自恋综艺节目，让他献出了人生中最精彩的表演。
I sprinted across the intersection of-- I think it was Houston and First Avenue.
我冲过了十字路口——我想是休斯顿和第一大道。
While cars were moving?
当汽车在行驶时？
Oh, yeah.
噢，是的。
That's incredibly dangerous.
那极其危险。
Not if it's professional drivers on a closed course.
如果是在封闭赛道上有专业车手的话，那就不危险了。
At its height, everything he did was the right thing to be doing. He was a master of improvisation, following all the cues perfectly. And then he started getting tired and then exhausted. Everything was still a clue, but he wasn't sure what any of it meant anymore.
在他妄想的巅峰期，他做的一切都是正确的。他是即兴表演的大师，完美地跟随所有的暗示。然后他开始感到疲倦，接着筋疲力尽。一切仍然是线索，但他不再确定这些意味着什么了。
Somewhere along the way, he lost his shirt and also his shoes. And the next thing he knew, he was standing on a Brooklyn subway platform, hands behind his head like a captured soldier, crying so hard, he flushed his contacts out of his eyes. All he wanted was for someone to yell, cut, thinking to himself--
在这个过程中，他弄丢了衬衫，也丢了鞋子。接着他发现自己站在布鲁克林的地铁站台上，双手抱头，像个被俘的士兵一样大哭，哭得太厉害，把隐形眼镜都冲出了眼眶。他只想要有人喊“卡”，心里想着——
OK, fine, you've got your shots. Can't you see that I'm bawling? Can't you see that I'm here suffering? Can't you see that I'm done? Like, come out, come out, wherever you are, Mr. Producer.
好吧，够了，你们已经拍够素材了。你们看不出我正在嚎啕大哭吗？看不出我正痛苦不堪吗？看不出我受够了吗？出来吧，出来吧，不管你在哪，制作人先生。
So I'm crying. And I just scream, what do you want from me? Two cops come up. Their uniforms look real-- super real.
所以我大哭。我大喊：“你们到底想从我这儿得到什么？”两个警察走过来。他们的制服看起来是真的——超级真。
The next thing I recall with any clarity is being in the back of an ambulance.
我能清晰记得的下一件事就是躺在救护车后面。
Huh.
哼。
And eventually, I hear a radio crack on. It's like, psh. Intake available at Bellevue Psych Ward.
最后，我听到无线电响了。就像是，“滋——贝尔维尤精神病院有接收名额。”
Zack was eventually diagnosed with bipolar disorder type I, which can involve psychosis sometimes. In Zack's case, lack of sleep and daily pot smoking might have triggered the episode. At Bellevue, he says they dosed him up with antipsychotics. At times, he could barely lift his chin off of his chest. He drooled a lot. He couldn't go outside. Zack's only experience with psych wards before this was as a public defender, representing EDPs, or emotionally disturbed people. And now he was one.
扎克最终被诊断为I型双相障碍，有时会伴有精神病症状。在扎克的案例中，缺乏睡眠和每天吸食大麻可能诱发了这次发作。在贝尔维尤，他说他们给他服用了抗精神病药物。有时他甚至无法把下巴从胸口抬起来。他流了很多口水。他不能去外面。扎克在此之前接触精神病院的唯一经历是作为公设辩护律师，代理EDP，也就是情感障碍患者。现在他自己也成了其中一员。
The delusion that he was on TV lasted in one form or another for the next 10 days. When he saw his mother, Cindy, coming down the hall on day two, he wasn't sure at first if it was her or an actor in prosthetics. He calls her bird because of the way she snaps her head back and forth sometimes.
关于他在电视上的妄想在某种程度上持续了接下来的10天。当他在第二天看到他的母亲辛迪走过大厅时，他起初不确定那是她本人还是戴着假体的演员。他叫她“鸟”，因为她有时前后猛甩头的方式。
The bird is here, she told him. The bird can't be here, he said. The bird lives in Wichita. She said, the bird got on a plane.
“鸟来了，”她告诉他。“鸟不可能在这儿，”他说，“鸟住在威奇托。”她说，“鸟坐了飞机过来。”
It took more than a year and a couple more episodes like this before he got stable. Along the way, he figured out a few things. He had to be good about taking his meds, and sleep was key. He couldn't burn the candle at all ends, like he had been, going on stage all the time. So he stopped, for the most part. He kept working his day job as a lawyer. They say you have to be at least a little crazy to be a comedian. But it's also possible to be so crazy that you can't be a comedian.
在他稳定下来之前，他经历了超过一年和几次类似的发作。在这一过程中，他明白了一些事。他必须按时服药，睡眠是关键。他不能像以前那样整天熬夜，频繁上台表演。所以他大部分时间停止了。他继续做着律师的日常工作。人们常说喜剧演员必须得有一点疯狂。但也可能疯狂到根本无法成为喜剧演员。
Zack has told the story of the psychotic break countless times at this point. It's a good romp, and he's got it down-- all the different parts. He tells it entertainingly. But while it's one thing to recount something like that from memory, it's another thing if someone catches it on video. You can actually see yourself in psychosis. I say this because after Zack got better and thought he was totally out of the woods, sanity wise, he did have another psychotic break. And it was captured on video. And for the first time in his life, sane Zack would be able to see himself in the midst of Truman Show delusion.
扎克已经无数次讲过这次精神崩溃的故事了。这确实是一场不错的闹剧，他掌握得很好——所有不同的部分。他讲得很有趣。但虽然凭记忆讲述那样的事情是一回事，如果有视频录下来又是另一回事。你真的可以看到自己处于精神病状态。我之所以这么说，是因为扎克康复后，以为自己完全走出了困境，但在理智方面，他又一次精神崩溃了。而且这次被视频拍下来了。这是他人生中第一次，理智的扎克能够看到自己在楚门秀妄想中的样子。
Do you need to call the cops, or is he OK?
你需要报警吗，还是他没事？
Yeah.
是的。
Shut the fuck up!
闭嘴！
Actually, let me-- sorry, I'm just going to stop that and explain what happened. So after a while, Zack quit lawyering and decided to try to make it as a writer. He wrote a book about that first psychotic break and his disorder, called Gorilla and the Bird. Gorilla is Zack's nickname because he's really hairy and barrel chested. Again, the bird is his mom. It was optioned for a TV series before it even came out. HBO is planning to run it. The director Jean-Marc Vallée, who did Big Little Lies and Sharp Objects, is on board.
实际上，让我——抱歉，我先停一下，解释一下发生了什么。在一段时间后，扎克辞去了律师工作，决定尝试成为一名作家。他写了一本关于那次精神崩溃和他的障碍的书，叫《大猩猩与鸟》。大猩猩是扎克的绰号，因为他体毛很重，胸部宽阔。还是那句话，鸟是他的妈妈。这本书还没出版就被电视连续剧买下了改编权。HBO正计划制作。执导了《大小谎言》和《利器》的导演让-马克·瓦雷已经加入了。
Zack and I have had entire conversations about who might play him on the TV show about the time he thought he was on a TV show and wasn't. In fact, his therapist said to him-- sort of joking, but sort of not-- you know, you might end up playing yourself on that show. To which Zack basically responded, yeah, I think they might want to go with one of these A-list celebrities they're considering.
扎克和我进行过完整的对话，讨论谁可能在关于他以为自己在电视上、但其实并不在那里的那段经历的电视剧中扮演他。事实上，他的治疗师曾开玩笑说——半开玩笑半认真——“你知道，你可能会最终在那个节目里扮演你自己。”扎克基本上回应说：“是啊，我想他们可能想选那些他们正在考虑的一线明星。”
And then, Zack was trying to figure out ways to promote his book. And of course, these days, a lot of authors make videos when their books come out. And so Zack hired a production crew to shoot footage for-- he wasn't sure what. A promotional video, but if it was any good, maybe they'd do a bigger documentary.
然后，扎克在想办法推广他的书。当然，现在的作者在新书出版时都会拍视频。所以扎克聘请了一个制作团队来拍摄素材——他也不确定拍什么。一个宣传视频，但如果效果好，或许他们会做一个更大的纪录片。
He wanted to take them back home with him to Wichita to interview some of the people that he'd written about in his memoir, meaning his family, and have the crew follow him around his hometown for a week, just rolling on everything, documentary style. The crew consisted of two professional cameramen and a very seasoned TV producer that Zack happened to be friends with. He'd been around the cameras a bunch before this, by the way. And it didn't trigger his disorder.
他想带他们回威奇托老家采访他书里写到的一些人，也就是他的家人，让摄制组跟着他在家乡拍摄一周，用纪录片的方式记录一切。摄制组由两名专业摄影师和一位扎克恰好是朋友的资深电视制作人组成。顺便说一句，他在这次之前已经接触过很多次摄像机了。这并没有触发他的障碍。
So the morning the delusion really hit, Zack hadn't met up with the film crew yet. They were actually wondering where he was. He was supposed to call. Instead, he was driving around Wichita by himself in his grandfather's pickup. He was fighting serious back pain. And he had barely slept in three days. Again, sleeplessness is a huge trigger for his episodes. In the book, he writes, "The solution to mania is so simple, yet so hard to come by. Just sleep." And the thing his therapist said came back to him-- that Jean-Marc Vallée might want him to play himself on the TV show.
所以妄想真正发作的那天早上，扎克还没有见到摄制组。他们其实还在纳闷他在哪儿。他本该打电话的。相反，他正独自开着他祖父的皮卡车在威奇托四处转悠。他忍受着严重的背痛。而且他已经三天几乎没睡了。同样，睡眠不足是他发作的巨大诱因。他在书里写道：“狂躁的解药很简单，却很难得到。只是睡觉。”他治疗师说的话浮现在他脑海里——让-马克·瓦雷可能希望他在电视剧里扮演他自己。
I came to believe that, oh my god, maybe my therapist was contacted by whoever. And maybe I really am auditioning for myself. So--
我开始相信，天哪，也许我的治疗师被某人联系过了。也许我真的在为我自己试镜。所以——
Right now. Like, I am auditioning to play the role of myself. I'm in the process of an audition.
就在此时此刻。就像，我正在试镜扮演我自己。我正处于试镜的过程中。
Yes. And I was just testing it slowly because I was like, be careful, you know? You've had this delusion before, and you've been wrong.
是的。我只是在慢慢测试，因为我当时想，小心点，你知道的？你以前有过这种妄想，结果是你错了。
And not only that, I know how the world works a little bit. I know HBO isn't just like, yeah, let him play himself. Great idea. Like, no. But like, I don't know. Maybe the director's kind of crazy. He takes a lot of risks.
不仅如此，我稍微了解这个世界的运作方式。我知道HBO不会仅仅是，“好啊，让他演他自己。好主意。”不，不会的。但，我不知道。也许导演有点疯狂。他冒了很多险。
And sitting in the truck, he started to have the feeling that in addition to the people he knew would be filming him later that day, there were also other cameras that he couldn't see, and maybe audio recorders, too, possibly right there in the truck with him.
坐在卡车里，他开始有种感觉，除了他知道那天晚些时候会拍他的人之外，还有他看不见的摄像机，也许还有录音机，可能就在卡车里跟他在一起。
I was listening to a song in his truck, and I was kind of dancing a little bit. And I was like, oh, this is kind of funny. And I was like, well, maybe you're not being taped right now. That's quite possible. That makes sense.
我在卡车里听着一首歌，然后有点小跳舞。我当时想，哦，这挺有趣的。我想，嗯，也许你现在没被录下来。这很有可能。那说得通。
I was like, but maybe you are. So maybe just give them a little something to think about. Leave them with something, like, OK, he's got a little something there. He's raw, and he needs training. But we got something we can possibly work with here.
我想，但也许你正在被录下来。所以，也许就给他们一点值得思考的东西。留给他们点什么，就像，“好吧，他那儿有点货。他很生涩，需要训练。但我们确实有些可以运作的东西。”
So once again, the powers that be had spotted Zack's latent talent and set it up so he could just do his thing in the wild-- wow the crowd.
所以再一次，权能者发现了扎克的潜能，并设置好一切，让他可以在野外展现自己——惊艳众人。
Should we watch the video?
我们要看视频吗？
If we must.
如果必须的话。
Let's watch the video.
让我们看视频。
This is going to hurt.
这会很伤人。
Really?
真的吗？
I think so.
我想是的。
How come?
为什么？
Well, I think I'm going to feel bad for the dude I'm going to watch, who is me.
好吧，我想我会为我即将看到的那个家伙感到难过，那个人就是我。
So the video-- it starts with the production crew in their car without Zack. It's just one cameraman and Zack's TV producer friend, Jay. They're heading to a taco shop to meet Zack. They pull up to a standalone building surrounded by a big parking lot. And they arrive at the same time as Zack's family friend, Rob, an older guy with a white beard and a tan ball cap.
所以视频——开始时是制作团队在没有扎克的车里。只有一个摄像师和扎克的电视制作人朋友杰伊。他们正前往一家塔可店去见扎克。他们开到了一栋被大型停车场包围的独立建筑前。他们到达时，扎克的家庭朋友罗伯，一个长着白胡子、戴着棕色棒球帽的老年人也刚好到了。
The cameraman's walking around the side of the taco place. And there you are.
摄像师走在塔可店旁边。看，你就在那儿。
Hm.
嗯。
Oh, man.
噢，伙计。
Yeah.
是啊。
Zack's in a spider-man crouch with his hands on the ground, staring down. He's wearing an Adidas t-shirt and sweatpants. No glasses-- he dropped them somewhere, which means he can't see anything. He's clearly in a lot of physical pain. It's his back, and it's spasming.
扎克正蹲在地上，像蜘蛛侠一样，双手着地，盯着下方。他穿着阿迪达斯的T恤和运动裤。没有戴眼镜——他把眼镜弄丢了，这意味着他什么都看不见。他显然身体非常痛苦。是他的背，正在痉挛。
I'm on my hands and knees now. I'm trying to stand up. I can't.
我正四肢着地。我试图站起来。我做不到。
You OK, dude?
你还好吗，伙计？
Yeah, I just got to stand up.
是的，我只是得站起来。
Is he OK?
他没事吧？
Pedestrians are asking if I'm OK.
行人在问我还好吗。
Yeah, he's just-- his back's a little hurt. His back's a little hurt. He's fine.
是的，他只是——他背有点疼。他背有点疼。他没事。
My friend Jay is saying, he's OK. He's OK.
我的朋友杰伊在说，他没事。他没事。
It wasn't 100% clear what was going on with Zack at that point. And Jay and the others were trying to help him, to get him into a car so he could get back to his hotel and sleep. But they also kept filming because that was the entire goal of the week. And they thought Zack might want this footage. This is exactly what his book was about. And here it was happening.
当时扎克身上到底发生了什么并不完全清楚。杰伊和其他人都在试图帮助他，让他上车去酒店睡觉。但他们仍然继续拍摄，因为那是那一周的全部目标。他们认为扎克可能想要这些素材。这就是他的书的内容。而这一切正在发生。
Zack, meanwhile, was now pretty convinced he was auditioning to play the role of himself on the TV show that, again, is actually being produced about the time he thought he was on a TV show. Some blurry calculus told him that his producer friend Jay and Jean-Marc Vallée must be in communication somehow. In the video, Zack's on his knees, swaying back and forth in front of the taco stand. He closes his eyes, then opens them, and looks toward the camera-- the one that isn't there.
与此同时，扎克现在非常确信他正在试镜出演那部电视节目中的自己，那个节目，再说一次，实际上就是关于他以为自己在拍电视节目那件事制作的。一些模糊的计算让他认为他的制片人朋友杰伊和让-马克·瓦雷一定以某种方式保持着联系。在视频里，扎克跪在塔可店前，前后摇晃。他闭上眼睛，然后睁开，看向摄像机——那个并不存在的摄像机。
Hold on. Hold on. Ah. All right. Too much. Too much.
等等。等等。啊。好吧。太多了。太多了。
And I'm saying, too much. Too much.
我在说，太多了。太多了。
Too much. Too much. Too much. Too much. Stop. Stop. Stop.
太多了。太多了。太多了。太多了。停。停。停。
It was freaky to see my friend like this. I've seen people in the park or on the subway, acting like Zack was that day. They're just so literally lost and don't know it. But you know it. It's like they're right beside you on the sidewalk and also in a forest that they can't be guided out of, not easily. But in this case, Zack was sitting next to me, watching with me. And he remembers everything that was going through his head at that moment.
看到我朋友这样真是太诡异了。我见过公园里或者地铁上的人，行为举止就像那天的扎克一样。他们真的迷失了方向，却不自知。但你知道。就像他们就在人行道上就在你旁边，同时也处在一个他们无法轻易被引导出来的森林里。但在这种情况下，扎克就坐在我旁边，和我一起看。他记得那一刻他脑子里经过的一切。
I came to believe that through some combination of Jean-Marc and my friend here, Jay, the producer, that we had maybe a yoga instructor who was watching my movements and could tell, by the way I was moving, how much pain I was in and where I was in pain. Oh, man. You know what? I think I thought they were even shocking my spine somehow.
我开始相信，通过让-马克和我在这里的朋友、制作人杰伊的某种结合，也许有个瑜伽教练在观察我的动作，并且能通过我移动的方式看出我有多疼以及我在哪里疼。哦，伙计。你知道吗？我想我当时甚至认为他们是在以某种方式电击我的脊椎。
Those back spasms-- he thought they were electrical shocks being triggered by this magical, imaginary yoga instructor. He moves in and out of different yoga poses on the ground.
那些背部痉挛——他认为是被这个神奇的、虚构的瑜伽教练触发的电击。他在地上做出各种不同的瑜伽姿势。
And I think that they're thinking that, if we shocked him this way, he would not only move his body to correct his posture that would alleviate his pain, but it can also point him toward whatever camera was capturing the particular footage that was going to be sent to Jean-Marc Vallée, the real director of the real series, Gorilla and the Bird.
我想他们当时在想，如果我们这样电击他，他不仅会移动身体来矫正姿势以减轻疼痛，还能引导他朝向任何捕捉特定素材的摄像机，这些素材会被送给让-马克·瓦雷，即真正的系列剧《大猩猩与鸟》的真正导演。
Oh, I see. So it was both to help you and also for production values.
哦，我明白了。所以既是为了帮助你，也是为了拍摄质量。
Right. And when you see me waving my hand and waving them off, that means, I'm not good right now. I don't really want to be shot.
对。当你看到我挥手把他们赶走时，意思就是，我现在状态不好。我真的不想被拍。
But you're not saying, stop filming, to the person who's filming this.
但你不是在对正在拍摄的人说“停止拍摄”。
No.
不。
You're saying that to--
你是在对——
The larger production team that doesn't exist.
那个不存在的更大的制作团队说。
Stop. For real, stop.
停。认真的，停。
Which, when you think about it, takes a certain type of genius. Because Zack's original delusion that he was being followed around by cameras had come true, his brain had to come up with a second level delusion that, again, involved real people. The way he explained it to me, it's not like he forgets reality or hallucinates that the camera is really a dragon or something. He's able to take in all the data in front of him. It's just that he comes to the wrong conclusions about it.
仔细想想，这需要某种天才。因为扎克最初关于他被摄像机跟踪的妄想成真了，他的大脑必须想出一个涉及真实人物的二级妄想。他向我解释时说，并不是说他忘记了现实或者幻觉到摄像机真的是条龙什么的。他能接收面前所有的信息。只是他得出了错误的结论。
So you do that. I'll get the Ativan.
所以你就那么做。我去拿安定。
Finally, Zack makes it to his feet and then walks off to the middle of the parking lot, sticks his hand in the air, and again, says, too much. Too much. Too much. Way too much. And then he's back down on his knees and finally on his back, lying in the parking lot as cars pass him.
最终，扎克站了起来，走到了停车场中间，把手举在半空中，又一次说：“太多了。太多了。太多了。简直太多了。”然后他又跪了下去，最后倒在背上，躺在停车场里，任由车辆从他身边经过。
Ah ah ah ah ah! Stop, stop, stop, stop.
啊啊啊啊啊！停，停，停，停。
Zack was right about what he said before, that it was going to hurt to watch this.
扎克之前说得对，看这个会很痛苦。
I think I'm kind of just like, oof, oof. I think I'm just bracing myself for it the whole time. And I'm kind of like rooting for the guy and feeling bad for him. And like, buddy, oh, please stop. Oh, please stop. But in the same way I would feel bad for someone I saw on the street who's yelling at pigeons--
我想我就像这样，“呜，呜”。我想我全程都在为它做心理准备。我有点在为那个家伙加油，又为他感到难过。就像，“兄弟，哦，请停下。哦，请停下。”但这就像我看到街上冲着鸽子大喊大叫的人，我会为他感到难过一样——
Right.
对。
Or whatever, you know? The difference is, I know that guy a little better.
之类的，你知道吗？区别在于，我比那个人了解得更深一点。
You know the guy that we saw in the video a little better.
你比我们在视频里看到的那个家伙了解得更深一点。
I do.
确实。
Yeah.
是啊。
Finally, they managed to get Zack back to his hotel. And this is when we learn about a whole other side of psychotic Zack, one that's even harder for sane Zack to watch. So Rob stays behind. And the cast is now Jay, the TV producer friend, and now two cameramen, Trevar and Tyler.
最后，他们设法把扎克带回了酒店。这时我们了解到了狂躁的扎克另一面，这是理智的扎克更难以面对的。罗伯留在了后面。现在的演员阵容是杰伊、那位电视制作人朋友，还有两名摄像师，特雷瓦和泰勒。
They went and got all of Zack's stuff from his mom's house, where he'd been staying earlier-- his medication, and his clothes, and everything. And they roll up to Zack's hotel room door with one of those standard issue luggage carts. Zack's in the room, talking to his mom on speaker phone. Job one is to get an Ativan into Zack to put him to sleep. And they also keep shooting.
他们去他妈妈家拿回了扎克所有的东西，他早些时候一直住在那里——他的药、他的衣服，还有一切。他们推着那种标准行李车到了扎克的酒店房间门口。扎克在房间里，正用免提电话和他妈妈通话。第一任务是给扎克服下安定让他睡觉。他们也一直在拍摄。
[KNOCKING]
[敲门声]
He opens the door, and there are two cameras pointing at him.
他打开门，两台摄像机对着他。
Holy shit.
天啊。
Oh.
哦。
What's up, boys?
什么事，伙计们？
You're in sunglasses and a towel.
你戴着墨镜，裹着毛巾。
I got your stuff.
我把你的东西拿来了。
It's like Kanye West has answered the door here. Zack was about to take a shower, and he needed to see. The sunglasses are prescription. Jay had his regular ones.
就像坎耶·韦斯特来开门一样。扎克正要洗澡，他需要看清东西。墨镜是处方镜。杰伊拿了他的普通眼镜。
Let me bring this. Let me just go here. I'm going to let you turn that corner.
让我带这个进去。我就去这儿。我要让你拐那个弯。
I'm kind of hamming it up there. I said let me go here, and I'll going to let you turn that corner.
我在那里有点做作。我说“让我去这儿，我要让你拐那个弯”。
Yeah, you're doing a voice.
是啊，你在装腔作势。
Yeah.
是啊。
Your coconut oil.
你的椰子油。
Mm-hmm.
嗯哼。
Your glasses.
你的眼镜。
Oh, that's nice to have.
哦，那带着很好。
Your wallet.
你的钱包。
Zack's pretty disoriented at this point. His mom, the bird, chimes in on speaker phone sometimes, trying to talk him down. And even though Zack's discombobulated about almost everything, he still thinks he's playing a role, even if that role is himself. The blinking red light in his head is still on. All the while, Jay is being really caring toward him.
扎克这时候非常混乱。他的妈妈，“鸟”，有时会在免提电话里插话，试图让他冷静下来。即使扎克对几乎所有事情都感到困惑，他仍然认为自己在扮演一个角色，即使那个角色就是他自己。他头脑里的闪烁红灯仍然亮着。与此同时，杰伊对他表现得非常关心。
How are you feeling?
你感觉怎么样？
I'm feeling a little shocked, like literally and figuratively.
我感觉有点被震到了，从字面意义上和比喻意义上来说。
By all this display of--
通过所有这些显示——
Oh, hold on.
哦，等等。
Jay was about to say something like, by all of this display of generosity and caring? But of course, Zack means he was being shocked by a magical yoga instructor. And he's also amazed at all of the planning that went into this audition.
杰伊本来想说些类似“所有这些慷慨和关怀的显示”的话？但当然，扎克是指他被那个神奇的瑜伽教练电击了。而且他也对他为这次试镜所做的所有计划感到惊叹。
[INAUDIBLE] Let's quit acting and let me just fucking coconut oil my ass.
[听不清] 不演了，让我他妈涂点椰子油。
Cool.
酷。
All right.
好吧。
Did you say, let's quit acting?
你刚才说，不演了？
Mm-hmm.
嗯哼。
So I can coconut oil my ass.
这样我可以给屁股涂点椰子油。
Mm-hmm. Which I guess if you think you're acting and someone's filming you, then you are acting. Coconut oil on that ass now.
嗯哼。我想如果你认为你在表演，有人在拍你，那你就在表演。现在给屁股涂点椰子油。
Oh, you were literally coconut oiling your ass.
哦，你真的在给屁股涂椰子油。
Yes.
是的。
Oh, I thought that was a euphemism.
哦，我还以为那是委婉语。
No, I do that.
不，我确实那样做。
Jay, where are my real glasses? Give me my real glasses. Oh, I got them.
杰伊，我真正的眼镜在哪儿？给我真正的眼镜。哦，我拿到了。
Barking orders like a real asshole. And--
像个混蛋一样咆哮着下命令。而且——
Take it off. Take it off speaker.
拿开。把扬声器拿开。
I'm kind of being an overall diva here.
我在那里表现得像个全面爆发的男主角。
It's true. Like, with the coconut oil, Zack comes out of the bathroom at one point with the jar and asks if someone can put some on his back. And this is probably the cringiest moment of the whole video for Zack to watch, mostly because the Zack in the video doesn't have any problem bossing everyone around. Trevar puts his camera down and complies.
这是事实。就像椰子油，扎克有一次拿着罐子走出浴室，问有没有人能帮他涂点在背上。对于扎克来说，这可能是整个视频中最让人尴尬的时刻，主要是因为视频里的扎克对命令别人完全没有任何问题。特雷瓦放下摄像机照办了。
Just dip a little and just hit me.
蘸一点，就拍打我。
All right. I see how this works.
好吧。我知道这怎么回事了。
Yeah, yeah. You got it. Don't rub it in.
是啊，是啊。你懂的。别使劲搓。
Not hard.
别太用力。
Yeah, no.
是啊，没。
Just, it's all around.
就，涂开。
We're just moisturizing.
我们在润肤。
All right.
好的。
No, no.
不，不。
Well, I'm not rubbing hard. I'm not rubbing hard.
好吧，我没用力搓。我没用力搓。
No, I mean-- all right.
不，我是说——好吧。
I'm just rubbing it around.
我只是把它涂开。
Good. We're fine. Yeah.
好。我们没事了。是啊。
Yeah. Lower. There you go.
是啊。下面。就这样。
Yeah.
是啊。
Zackary, can you hear me?
扎克，你能听见我吗？
I can hear you.
我能听见。
You need to--
你需要——
Look, I'm just oiling up, all right? Hey.
听着，我只是在抹油，好吗？嘿。
Is that good?
这样好吗？
Stop. Stop. No. That's not what we do.
停。停。不。这不是我们该做的。
You're like, stop, stop. No, that's not good. You're not putting coconut oil on my back right.
你就像，“停，停。不，这样不好。你没把椰子油抹在我背上。”
Yeah.
是啊。
Just, like, rub it. Just--
就，涂它。就——
Now Jay is doing it.
现在杰伊在弄了。
Not like-- no, just like you're putting lotion on. Hard. Harder, harder. Just rub that shit in.
不是这样——不，就像你涂乳液一样。用力。用力，用力。把那玩意儿揉进去。
That's really painful to watch. It's just I'm being such a dick to everybody.
看那段真是太痛苦了。我当时对每个人都太刻薄了。
Well, you're here in a florid psychotic episode.
好吧，你当时处于明显的精神病发作中。
That's true. But I'm still not being nice. And no one there knows me all that well. I mean, Jay knows me best at this point here. But this is the first he's seen me be in any sort of bad mental state. And he's got kids at home. He's got a newborn. And he took time out of his schedule to come do this, for free. And he is taking care of me.
那是真的。但我当时仍然没表现得好。而且那里没有人很了解我。我是说，杰伊这时最了解我。但这是他第一次看到我处于任何糟糕的精神状态。他家里有孩子。他有刚出生的宝宝。他从日程里抽出时间免费来做这件事。而且他在照顾我。
He's babysitting you, kind of.
他在照顾你，某种程度上。
Yeah, and he's hiding his exasperation while he deals with me. But then you can see when he's looking at the camera-- I won't call it eye rolling, but it's just like, the guy's obviously frustrated and being pushed to the limits of his patience. He's doing everything perfect here. It's amazing what he's doing.
是啊，他在应付我的同时隐藏了他的恼怒。但你可以看到当他看向镜头时——我不会称之为翻白眼，但这就像，这家伙显然感到挫败，耐心被推向极限。他在这里所做的一切都很完美。他做的事情太了不起了。
And so when I see that video, it makes me want to call Jay, my friend in the video, and say, hey, man. I'm sorry I spoke to you like that, and I'm sorry that I brought that stress into your life. But then out of the other side of my mouth, I'll preach to the general public, like, ain't your fault.
所以当我看到那个视频时，它让我想要给视频里的朋友杰伊打电话，说：“嘿，兄弟。抱歉我那样对你说话，抱歉我把那种压力带进了你的生活。”但转头我却会向公众宣扬，“这不是你的错。”
When he does speaking events at bookstores and other places, talking about his disorder, he says, people shouldn't be ashamed of their own mental illness and their behavior during episodes like this one. His mantra is always, this happens, and it's OK.
当他在书店和其他地方举行演讲活动，谈论他的障碍时，他说人们不应该因为自己的精神疾病以及像这一发作期间的行为而感到羞耻。他的口头禅总是：“这会发生的，没关系。”
Because I do believe this happens, and it is OK, as it relates to everyone else. But when I see it happen to myself, I'm like, that's not OK, man. You got to get your shit together.
因为我确实相信这会发生，而且没关系，只要涉及到其他人。但当我在自己身上看到它发生时，我就想：那可没关系，老兄。你得搞定你自己。
The Ativan's starting to take effect. Zack's getting drowsy. He has to fly back to LA the next day, but it's not clear he understands that. The bird on speaker phone has been steadily beating a drum, trying to coax him away from the cameras-- the real ones and the imaginary ones-- and just get him to go to bed. Sleep, of course, is the opposite of performing.
安定开始起效了。扎克变得昏昏欲睡。他第二天得飞回洛杉矶，但并不清楚他是否理解这一点。扬声器里的“鸟”一直在敲鼓，试图诱导他远离摄像机——那些真实的和想象中的——然后去睡觉。睡觉，当然，与表演背道而驰。
Zack, now that you've got your Ativan on board, you just need to lay down, son.
扎克，既然你已经吃了安定，你就得躺下，孩子。
Yeah, you're right.
是啊，你是对的。
You don't need to worry about the clothing right now. So Zack, you just need to go to sleep. And then, you just need to coordinate with Trevar how to get you to the airport for your flight.
你现在不用担心衣服了。所以扎克，你只需要去睡觉。然后，你只需要和特雷瓦协调如何去机场赶你的航班。
Oh, yeah, because I have my earplugs now.
哦，是啊，因为我现在有耳塞了。
It looks like he's getting ready to go to sleep. He hangs up with his mom, but then after everyone leaves, he calls her back. Says to her, what the hell just happened? She says, what do you think happened?
看起来他准备去睡觉了。他挂断了和他妈妈的电话，但每个人走后，他又拨了回去。他说：“刚才到底发生了什么？”她说：“你认为发生了什么？”
He says, I'm Jake Gyllenhaal. No, she says. There's going to be a TV show made out of your book, but you are Zack. You aren't messing with me, he says. Nothing happened just now? Nothing, she says. You need to sleep. You're manic.
他说：“我是杰克·吉伦哈尔。”“不，”她说，“会有关于你那本书的电视节目，但你是扎克。”“你没在跟我开玩笑吧，”他说，“刚才什么都没发生？什么都没发生，”她说，“你得睡觉了。你狂躁了。”
I'm just crushed that that just happened to me. In this moment, I'm kind of realizing that my mind has betrayed me.
我当时崩溃了，因为刚才发生在我身上的一切。那一刻，我意识到我的大脑背叛了我。
Again.
又一次。
Yeah. And I just feel so fucking stupid--
是啊。我感觉自己他妈的太蠢了——
Oh, honey.
哦，亲爱的。
And so embarrassed. I mean, this is humiliating, you know? And it causes chaos, fault or no fault. I wish it was easier to be my friend. I wish I took up less space in the people that love me's lives.
太尴尬了。我是说，这真是丢脸，你知道吗？它造成了混乱，无论过错在谁。我希望做我的朋友能容易点。我希望我在爱我的人的生活中占据的空间少一点。
I watch the video several more times on my own. And I realize that maybe there's this one other thing that's unsettling for Zack when he sees the scene in the hotel room. Zack told me he doesn't want to be on TV anymore like he used to. But it's clear his delusion still does. The Zack in the hotel room still has this naked, unfettered ambition of wanting to perform, wanting all the cameras on him.
我独自一人又看了几次那个视频。我意识到扎克在看酒店房间那段时，可能还有另一件不安的事。扎克告诉我他不再像过去那样想上电视了。但很明显，他的妄想仍然想。酒店房间里的扎克仍然有一种裸露的、不受束缚的想要表演的野心，想要所有的摄像机都对着他。
It's almost like a little kid's dream of stardom. The towel around his waist could just as easily be tied around his neck, superhero style. And the Zack watching the video is bashful about that, in a way that the Zack in the video is not. I didn't think to ask him about this when we were watching it together. So I called him later and said it on the phone.
这几乎就像小孩子对明星梦的渴望。他腰间的毛巾完全可以系在脖子上，像超级英雄那样。而在看视频的扎克对此感到害羞，而视频里的扎克则不然。我们在一起看的时候我没想过问他这个。所以我后来给他打电话，在电话里说了。
Yeah, I think that's probably-- yeah, I think that's probably true. It's almost like I've kind of renounced the hustle in my normal day to day, this naked pursuit of fame and stardom. But yeah, like you're saying, the id keeps going no, dude. You're not fooling anybody, least of all your own brain. This is what you want, except that you're a performer. Yeah, I'm so shy about my acting aspirations, I didn't even realize that.
是啊，我想那可能是——是啊，我想那可能是真的。这几乎就像我在日常生活中放弃了那种忙碌，这种对名利和明星地位的赤裸追求。但是的，就像你说的，本我一直坚持，“不，兄弟。你没在骗任何人，尤其是你自己的大脑。”这是你想要的，除了你是个表演者。是啊，我对我的演艺抱负太害羞了，我甚至都没意识到这一点。
It's sort of like sane Zack set the stage for delusional Zack to get what he wants-- to be the star. And now that there's video of it, sane Zack has to confront what that show actually looks like-- the Zack show. And he's not a fan.
这就像理智的扎克为狂躁的扎克搭好了舞台去得到他想要的——成为明星。而现在有了视频，理智的扎克必须面对那场表演看起来到底是什么样子——扎克秀。而他不是个粉丝。
The full title of Zack's book is Gorilla and the Bird, a Memoir of Madness and a Mother's Love. I could talk about how great, and hilarious, and important I think it is, but I've already annoyed a lot of people doing that. So, see for yourself. Coming up, that one mistake that haunts you, and you just can't get over it. And then, you watch the same screw-up happen all over again four decades later. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
扎克书的全名是《大猩猩与鸟，疯狂与母爱的回忆录》。我可以谈论我认为它有多棒、多有趣、多重要，但我已经为此惹恼了很多人。所以，你自己看吧。接下来，那个缠绕着你、让你无法释怀的错误。然后，四十年后，看着同样的失误再次发生。那将在一分钟后从芝加哥公共广播电台播出，当我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life. And I'm Sean Cole in for Ira Glass. Today's show-- Seeing Yourself in the Wild, stories of people who get to-- reluctantly decide to-- come face to face with an unedited version of who they are and what they do with that information. And I am now delighted to bring you Act 2 of our show. Act 2, distant replay.
这里是《美国生活》。我是肖恩·科尔，代替艾拉·格拉斯主持。今天的节目——“在野外看到你自己”，讲述人们如何不得不——很不情愿地决定——去面对他们是谁的未剪辑版本，以及他们如何处理这些信息。我现在很高兴给你们带来我们节目的第二幕。第二幕，远距离重放。
So, this story is about a man who's been reliving this one moment from his life over and over again. He remembers every last detail of how it felt, how it changed his life. And then 40 years later, someone shows up with a recording of that thing. Emanuele Berry explains.
所以，这个故事关于一个男人，他一直在一遍又一遍地重温他生活中的那一刻。他记得那种感觉的每一个细节，它是如何改变了他的人生。然后40年后，有人带着那个东西的录音出现了。埃马努埃莱·贝里为您讲述。
The man is my dad. And the thing he cannot let go of is a high school basketball game from 1978. I found out about the game when I was a kid. My mom had saved this old newspaper clipping, or maybe it was a yearbook. But either way, there is this picture of my dad on a basketball court. And when I brought it to her, she told me not to ask my dad about it. And so, I never brought it up. But it bugged me, because basketball is the one thing my dad and I share.
那个男人是我爸爸。他无法放下的是1978年的一场高中篮球赛。我小时候发现了那场比赛。我妈妈留着那张旧报纸剪报，或者可能是毕业纪念册。但无论如何，照片里是我爸爸在篮球场上。当我把它拿给她看时，她告诉我不要问我爸爸关于它的事。所以，我从没提起过。但这一直困扰着我，因为篮球是我和我爸爸共同拥有的东西。
Of my four siblings, I'm the only one who fell for the game like my dad. I loved being on the court; the sound of squeaking shoes, creaking floors; the way the entire space of the gym would vibrate; the way my body would twist, and turn, and pivot to the basket. I loved basketball, but I also loved the attention my dad gave me because of it. In the car after games, we'd annoy the hell out of the rest of my family by dissecting my every move, figuring out what I could improve on, what I did well. It was like we were speaking our own language. Together, we laid out big dreams for my future-- club teams, high school star, college, the WNBA.
在四个兄弟姐妹中，我是唯一一个像我爸爸一样迷上这项运动的人。我喜欢在球场上的感觉；球鞋摩擦声，地板吱吱声；整个体育馆空间都在震动的感觉；我的身体为了投篮而扭转、旋转和转向的方式。我热爱篮球，但我也热爱我爸爸因此而给我的关注。比赛后的车里，我们会通过剖析我的每一个动作，弄清楚我能改进什么，做得好的地方，来烦死我们家庭里的其他人。感觉我们是在说我们自己的语言。我们一起为我的未来规划了宏伟的梦想——俱乐部球队、高中明星、大学、WNBA。
But when I got to high school, I cared less about the game. Our postgame talk stopped feeling like conversations and started sounding like lectures. I started to dread the car rides home.
但我到了高中时，我不再那么关心比赛了。我们的赛后谈话不再像是对话，而听起来像是讲座。我开始害怕回家的车程。
And there's one ride for my junior year of high school that I still think about all the time. I was walking to my dad's car after the game. And as soon as I closed the door, it started. Why didn't you do this? You need to do this. How could you do this? As I listen to the steady rhythm of my dad's critique, I realized, these lectures weren't about me or what I wanted. They were about him.
我高二时有一次回家的车程，我一直还在想。比赛后我正走向我爸爸的车。我刚关上车门，就开始了。“为什么你不做这个？”“你需要做那个。”“你怎么能做那个？”当我听着爸爸批评的稳定节奏，我意识到，这些讲座不是关于我或者我想要的。它们是关于他自己的。
So I did something I had never done before. Shut the fuck up, I shouted. He was taken aback for a moment, and then stony silence, waiting for an apology. But it was an apology I wouldn't give. I told him that I didn't want to talk about basketball with him anymore. And if that's all he wanted to talk about, we didn't need to talk. So we didn't. For over a year, we barely spoke to each other.
所以我做了我以前从未做过的事。“他妈的闭嘴，”我喊道。他愣了一会儿，然后是死一样的沉默，等着道歉。但我绝不会道歉。我告诉他我不想再跟他谈论篮球了。如果那是他唯一想谈的话题，那我们就不必谈了。所以我们没谈。一年多来，我们几乎没说过话。
A lot of time has passed. I haven't picked up a ball in forever. Neither has my dad. The silence is long gone. But there's something that hasn't been repaired. Nowadays, we just exchange basketball pleasantries. Did you watch that game? How does the team look this year? LeBron, LeBron, LeBron.
时间过去很久了。我很久没碰过球了。我爸爸也没碰过。沉默早就消失了。但有些事情还没修复。如今，我们只是交换篮球客套话。“你看那场比赛了吗？”“球队今年看起来怎么样？”“勒布朗，勒布朗，勒布朗。”
Basketball gives us the illusion that we know each other. But I'm not sure we do. And I've been wanting to know my dad better-- to talk to him about something real, something that matters to him. So that high school basketball game from 1978 seems like a good place to start.
篮球给了我们一种我们了解彼此的错觉。但我并不确定我们真的了解。我一直想更了解我爸爸——和他谈论一些真实的事情，一些对他来说重要的事情。所以那场1978年的高中篮球赛似乎是个很好的起点。
I visited my parents in Michigan. And when I walk into the living room, of course, there's a college basketball game on in the background. My dad's in his usual position, sunken into his recliner. Even sitting down, he's still big. Long arms-- his hands make the remote look teeny. I ask him to talk upstairs.
我去了密歇根看望我父母。当我走进客厅时，当然，背景里正播放着一场大学篮球赛。我爸爸在他通常的位置，陷在他的躺椅里。即使坐着，他依然庞大。长长的手臂——他的手让遥控器看起来微不足道。我让他上楼聊聊。
On what?
聊什么？
Do you want to sit back here?
你想坐在后面吗？
Anywhere is OK with me.
在哪儿都行。
OK.
好吧。
I go to sleep.
我去睡觉了。
No, you can't go to sleep. We're talking.
不，你不能去睡觉。我们在聊天。
I'm nervous. My dad is intimidating. We chit chat for a long time before I bring up the game and that old photo my mom had kept.
我很紧张。我爸爸很有威慑力。在提起那场比赛和我妈妈保留的那张旧照片之前，我们聊了很久。
And I remember her saying that it was sad and that I shouldn't mention it.
我还记得她说那很伤感，我不该提它。
That picture was of the final game when we lost in the semifinals. I blame myself for losing that game.
那张照片是我们在半决赛输掉的最后一场比赛。我自责输了那场球。
Why?
为什么？
[DEEP SIGH]
[深呼吸]
There's a lot in that sigh. My dad grew up poor in Mississippi, the youngest of 11. And for him, basketball was a way to college. But in the 10th grade, he suffered a serious knee injury. His knee would swell when he ran, so he had to stop playing.
那个叹息里包含了很多。我爸爸在密西西比贫困长大，是11个孩子里最小的。对他来说，篮球是上大学的一条路。但在高一的时候，他遭遇了严重的膝伤。他跑步时膝盖会肿胀，所以不得不停止打球。
But he got an unlikely second chance. Before his senior year of high school, his family moved to Michigan. There, the surgeon found bone shards under my dad's kneecap. He removed them, and the swelling stopped. My dad could play basketball again. That dream to get a basketball scholarship to go to college was back on.
但他得到了一个不太可能的第二次机会。高三前夕，他全家搬到了密歇根。在那里，外科医生发现我爸爸的髌骨下有骨碎片。他移除了它们，肿胀消失了。我爸爸又能打篮球了。那个获得篮球奖学金上大学的梦想又回来了。
My dad joined his high school basketball team. They were called the Everett Vikings, and they were good. They'd won the state championship the previous year. The star of that team was this guy named Earvin. But most people just call him Magic Johnson. Even in high school, they called them that. The coach was thrilled when my dad joined because he was tall. And the team had lost Magic Johnson and all of their height. As the season progressed, my dad flourished. He was a strong rebounder. He could dunk. He even got a nickname.
我爸爸加入了他的高中篮球队。他们叫埃弗雷特维京队，他们很棒。他们前一年赢得了州冠军。那支球队的明星是一个叫厄文的家伙。但大多数人只是叫他“魔术师”约翰逊。甚至在高中时，他们就这么叫他。教练很兴奋，因为我爸爸加入了，他很高。而球队失去了“魔术师”约翰逊和他们所有的身高优势。随着赛季的推进，我爸爸风生水起。他是一个强大的篮板手。他会扣篮。他甚至得了个外号。
They wanted to try to figure out a name for me, a nickname for me. They already had one for Earvin. As everybody know, Tim Scott nicknamed Earvin "Magic" Johnson. One of the sportscasters found out I was from Mississippi. During a game where I dunked the ball, he said, Mississippi Slammer. That's where they got the name the Mississippi Slammer.
他们想给我起个名字，一个外号。他们已经给厄文起了一个。正如每个人所知，蒂姆·斯科特给厄文起了“魔术师”约翰逊这个绰号。其中一个体育播音员发现我来自密西西比。在一场我扣篮的比赛中，他说：“密西西比重击者。”他们就是从那儿得来的“密西西比重击者”这个外号。
His team was cruising through the season to the state playoffs, which brings us to the game I was never supposed to ask about. It was the semifinals. The team was supposed to wear suits to the game, but my dad didn't have one. So he had to get one at the last minute.
他的球队在赛季中高歌猛进，进入了州季后赛，这就带到了我本不该问的那场比赛。那是半决赛。球队本该穿西装去参加比赛，但我爸爸没有。所以他不得不在最后一分钟找了一套。
He missed the pep rally, and he got to the gym late. My dad remembers going to the locker room, the starting lineups being announced. And when the game started, he says he just felt off. He remembers this one play in particular, where he says everything fell apart.
他错过了动员大会，迟到了体育馆。我爸爸记得走进更衣室，首发阵容被宣布。比赛开始时，他说他感觉很不对劲。他记得特别是在那次进攻中，他说一切都崩盘了。
I grab a rebound off the backboard above the rim. And I go up above the rim, to where I'm basically-- all I had to do was just drop the ball in the basket. Instead, I threw it across the basket. And I never will forget it. It was hard on me because that was a turning point in the game that had made me feel that I lost the game.
我从篮圈上方的篮板抢下一个篮板。我跳到篮圈上方，基本上——我唯一要做的就是把球投进篮筐。相反，我把球扔过了篮圈。我永远不会忘记它。这对我来说很艰难，因为那是比赛的一个转折点，让我觉得是我输掉了比赛。
How long do you think you carried around that one little moment?
你觉得你把那一个小瞬间携带了多久？
I still carry it around. Obviously, I'm still talking about it.
我还在携带它。显然，我还在谈论它。
What do you think would make you not carry it around with you?
你认为什么会让你不再携带它？
I don't know. I can't go back in time and redo it.
我不知道。我不能回到过去重做一次。
They lost the game by just a few points.
他们以几分的优势输掉了比赛。
Did it feel like opportunities were closing for you with that game?
那场比赛让你感觉机会在关闭吗？
Yeah. If I had played better, and we would've won that game, we would have been in the finals. And there would've been more visual eyes on us. And the thing was is that I was only out there for one year because I came up here in my senior year. So nobody really knew who I was. For me to get the more exposure, we needed to continue to win. And when we didn't win, I think that just-- a lot of the opportunities for me to be seen went out the window. I have a lot of resentment about the opportunities that I feel that it could have changed my life from the way we are now.
是的。如果我打得更好，我们会赢得那场比赛，我们就会进入决赛。那样会有更多的视觉关注到我们身上。问题是我只打了一年，因为我高三才来到这里。所以没人真正知道我是谁。为了获得更多的曝光，我们需要继续赢。当我们没赢时，我想那只是——我觉得很多本可以改变我人生的机会就这样溜走了。对于我觉得本可以改变我们现在这种生活的机会，我有很多怨恨。
When my dad says where we are now, he means no college degree, a career managing restaurants, raising five kids, and making ends meet. Where we are now is missing part of a lung and slipped discs. Where we are now is no kidneys and dialysis, while still working 60 hour weeks. It's been over 40 years since he missed that shot. Maybe that's how long it takes to mourn an alternative universe.
当我爸爸说“我们现在这种生活”时，他指的是没有大学学位，做着餐厅管理，抚养五个孩子，勉强维持生计。我们现在所处的地方是肺部缺失了一部分和椎间盘突出。我们现在所处的地方是没有肾脏和透析，同时还要每周工作60小时。他错过那次投篮已经40多年了。也许这就是哀悼平行宇宙所需要的时间。
But part of me also wonders, isn't that long enough to let it go-- to see that it's just a game? That where we are now is also 40 years of marriage and kids who went to college, one even to Yale-- not me. And it's not like my dad hates his job. I've never thought of our life as anything other than a good one.
但我的一部分也在怀疑，这不是够长了吗，足以让它过去——看到那只是场比赛？“我们现在所处的地方”也是40年的婚姻和上了大学的孩子，甚至有一个上了耶鲁——不是我。而且并不是我爸爸讨厌他的工作。我从未认为我们的生活有任何不如意。
I got it in my head that if he could watch the game, he'd see things differently. Maybe he didn't play so badly. Maybe he's just being hard on himself. And I wanted to see it. I've never seen him play.
我脑子里产生了一个想法，如果他能看那场比赛，他会以不同的方式看待事情。也许他并没打得那么糟。也许他只是对自己太苛刻了。我想看那场比赛。我从没见过他打球。
So I looked for the tape everywhere-- his high school, TV stations, the Michigan High School Athletic Association. And then, a few months later, my dad reconnected with one of his high school teammates. And he said, I have a copy of the game. And not only that, but he and the other guys on the team had a different take of how my dad played. They said they remembered him playing great-- that he's the reason they even stayed in the game.
所以我到处寻找录像带——他的高中、电视台、密歇根州高中体育协会。然后，几个月后，我爸爸联系上了他的一位高中队友。他说：“我有一份比赛录像。”不仅如此，他和球队的其他家伙对我的打球方式有不同的看法。他们说他们记得他打得很棒——他是他们留在比赛中的原因。
He gave the tape to my dad. My dad tried to watch it once, but didn't get too far. So, a few weeks ago, we sat down in the living room to watch the game together.
他把录像带给了我爸爸。我爸爸试着看了一次，但没看太久。所以，几周前，我们坐在客厅一起看比赛。
All right, you ready?
好了，准备好了吗？
I think so.
我想是吧。
You think so? Are you worried right now?
你觉得是吧？你现在担心吗？
I'm nervous.
我很紧张。
Why? What are you nervous about?
为什么？你担心什么？
Watching myself 40 years ago playing basketball, revisiting those moments. But my teammates said that I played very like a bear, or beast, or whatever. I would like to see that part of the video. Versus what I perceive that I did not play very well. So from retrospective, I would like to see that version-- the beast.
看着40年前打球的自己，重温那些时刻。但我队友说我打得像头熊，或者野兽，或者别的什么。我想看录像的那部分。相比我所感知到的我没打好。所以从回顾的角度看，我想看那个版本——野兽。
The beast? The Mississippi Slammer?
野兽？密西西比重击者？
Well, you know, I'd take anything right now.
好吧，你知道，我现在什么都能接受。
Here we go.
我们开始了。
A grainy black and white court comes into focus. Players zoomed towards the basket and layup lines. Lots of them have afros.
一个颗粒状的黑白球场进入视线。球员们在篮筐和上篮线上来回穿梭。他们中很多人留着爆炸头。
Can you tell which one is me?
你能看出来哪个是我吗？
Um, not yet. Well, it's all over the place.
嗯，还没。好吧，到处都是。
And then I see him. It's his body language, so like my little brother's that it gives him away.
然后我看到了他。那是他的肢体语言，和我弟弟的太像了，直接暴露了他。
Is this you?
这是你吗？
That's me, yeah.
那是我是的。
Is that you?
那是你吗？
Yes, that's me.
是的，是我。
He's sporting a white jersey and teeny, tight white shorts that are very shy of his knees. Tube socks and high top sneakers-- the shoes make me cringe. Ankle support apparently was not a thing. And he's way skinnier than I've ever known him.
他穿着一件白色球衣，紧身的白色短裤离膝盖很远。筒袜和高帮球鞋——这些鞋让我觉得局促。踝关节支撑显然当时不是个事儿。他比我认识的任何时候都要瘦得多。
You're so teeny.
你太苗条了。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Yeah, all 189 pounds of me.
是的，我当时189磅重。
When was the last time you were 189 pounds.
你上一次189磅是什么时候。
Yeah, in high school.
是啊，在高中时。
Hold on, this game is underway.
等等，比赛开始了。
The teams line up at the big [INAUDIBLE] half court for the jump ball. My dad loses the jump. The other team picks the ball up on the court, fires off a quick jumper that bounces off the rim. My dad's team takes the ball down, and throws up a shot, and also misses. My dad grabs the rebound.
两队在半场争球。我爸爸丢了那个球。对方球队捡起球，投出一个快速跳投，弹框而出。我爸爸的球队带球下底，投篮，也投失了。我爸爸抢下篮板。
Bobby Berry has it.
鲍比·贝里拿到了球。
Bobby Berry-- that's my dad. The funny thing is that as he watches, he seems to forget that he knows how this game ends. And he's watching it like any other game on TV.
鲍比·贝里——那是我爸爸。有趣的是，当他看着的时候，他似乎忘记了他知道这场比赛的结局。他像看电视上的任何其他比赛一样看着它。
Come on.
来吧。
My dad's team scores the first two baskets. It's 4-0. But the lead doesn't seem to matter to him. He's already down on himself.
我爸爸的球队进了前两个球。4-0。但领先对他来说似乎并不重要。他已经对自己很失望了。
What are you seeing right now?
你现在看到了什么？
Me standing.
我站在那儿。
Yeah?
是吗？
Yep.
是的。
What do you mean?
什么意思？
Um, I don't go to the ball. I go away from the ball. Watch the ball come to this side. Now watch where I go-- opposite side of the ball.
嗯，我不去抢球。我远离球。看球来到这一侧。现在看我去了哪儿——球的另一侧。
I start to say things like, it just started. It's not that bad. I'm pointing out every good thing he does.
我开始说类似“这刚开始而已。没那么糟。”我指出他做的每一件好事。
Look, you just got an offensive rebound.
看，你刚拿了个进攻篮板。
And I'm so busy talking, I almost miss the play that's haunted my dad.
我太忙于说话了，差点错过了缠绕我爸爸的那次进攻。
[INAUDIBLE] Tony Daniel high post drives around his hand, puts it up-- no good.
[听不清] 托尼·丹尼尔高位运球，绕过他的手，投篮——没进。
You got the board.
你拿到球了。
There it is.
就是那个。
Is that the shot? Was that it?
那是投篮吗？是那个吗？
Yes. Yeah, that was the shot.
是的。是啊，那是那次投篮。
You want to--
你想——
[INAUDIBLE] No, I don't want to see it again. Once is enough.
[听不清] 不，我不想再看一遍。看一次就够了。
The play is over so quick. It's just a second on the screen. And the thing is after that shot, his teammate rebounds the ball and puts it in. In other words, the miss-- it didn't matter. They still score.
进攻很快就结束了。屏幕上只有一秒钟。关键是那次投篮后，他的队友抢下篮板投进了。换句话说，投失了——这没关系。他们还是得分了。
But it did matter to my dad. He never really recovers. And for the rest of the game, he misses shot after shot. Though it's not all bad. He makes a monster block on the next play. Though watching, he barely seems to notice. Next play down, he's fouled on the shot. So he gets two free throws.
但这对我爸爸有关系。他从没真正恢复过来。在比赛余下的时间里，他一次又一次投失。虽然也不全是坏事。他在接下来的进攻中做了一次怪物级的盖帽。虽然看着，他几乎没注意到。下一次进攻，他投篮被犯规了。所以他得到了两次罚球。
Yeah, free throws! That's what I mean.
是啊，罚球！我就是这个意思。
You made your free throw.
你罚进了。
I missed a shot, two feet away.
我投失了一个两英尺外的球。
I keep trying to get him to see what his teammates saw. He won't.
我一直试图让他看到他队友看到的东西。他不肯。
You guys are up by quite a bit.
你们领先不少。
Yeah, I know. That's the point. We lost.
是啊，我知道。重点是。我们输了。
At halftime, it's 22-21. My dad's team is up by one. But by the second half, it's as if my dad remembers what he's watching and how it ends. No more yelling, he just sort of sits hand over mouth, quiet.
中场休息时，比分是22-21。我爸爸的球队领先一分。但到了下半场，似乎我爸爸记起了他在看什么以及它是如何结束的。不再大喊，他只是捂着嘴坐着，安静。
And this is where I start to think, wait, is he mad at me? I start to worry that this was a terrible idea. This isn't going to make him feel better. Rather than think about one mistake in a game from 40 years ago, he can now watch 40 minutes of mistakes.
这时我开始想，等等，他在生我气吗？我开始担心这是个糟糕的主意。这不会让他感觉更好。与其思考40年前一场比赛中的一次错误，他现在可以看40分钟的错误。
The game remains close. And I can see what his teammates are saying about him being a beast. He's pulling down lots of rebounds. He is the reason they're still in the game. But he's not scoring much. Then, in the fourth quarter, their opponent pulls ahead by just a few. And my dad's team can't catch up. It's over.
比赛依然胶着。我能看到他队友说的关于他是野兽的话。他摘下很多篮板。他是他们依然留在比赛中的原因。但他得分不多。然后，在第四节，他们的对手领先了几分。我爸爸的球队追不上。结束了。
The camera shows one final moment of my dad. It zooms in on him before he heads into the locker room. He leans down, wrapping his arms around his coach, consoling him. My father at the kitchen table has far less compassion for himself.
摄像机记录了我爸爸的一个最后瞬间。在进入更衣室之前，镜头聚焦在他身上。他弯下腰，双臂搂着他的教练，安慰他。厨房桌前的我父亲对自己却缺乏同情心。
How are you feeling?
你感觉怎么样？
Uh, depressed. But I can't do anything about it. It's like I said. It's sad to see that game over again, that's for sure. And I didn't-- still, I feel the same way. I felt that I did not play very well, the way I felt that I should.
呃，沮丧。但我无能为力。就像我说的。看到那场比赛再次结束，真是令人伤心，这是肯定的。我没——依然，我感觉一样。我觉得我没打好，我觉得我本该打好的那种方式。
My dad finally got to see how this moment actually looked from the outside. And it didn't change anything for him.
我爸爸终于看到了那一刻从外部看起来是什么样。这对他来说并没有改变什么。
You can't imagine that things were different. The tape proves the way I felt that I played is what the tape shows.
你无法想象事情本可以不同。录像带证明我感觉我打球的方式就是录像带显示的。
When we were watching, I worried that I'd upset my dad. I had.
我们看的时候，我担心我惹我不爸爸不高兴了。我的确惹了。
Well, you're reopening a wound.
好吧，你重新打开了一个伤口。
Me?
我？
Yes. Why are you making me watch this game?
是的。为什么要让我看这场比赛？
Does it make you that upset?
让你那么沮丧吗？
I'm not upset. It just reopens it, and making me revisit it is not necessarily making me--
我不沮丧。它只是重新打开了它，让我重温它并不一定让我——
See, I think my hope was that by watching it, it would make you feel better. Like, you could let go of it.
看，我认为我的希望是，通过看它，它会让你感觉更好。就像，你可以放下它。
The only way I probably can ever let go of it is go back into time and reverse everything. And that's not going to happen.
我唯一能放下它的方法大概是回到过去改变一切。那是不可能发生的。
Is that really what it would take?
真的需要那样才能放下吗？
I think that's probably what it would take.
我想那大概就是所需要的。
I think it makes me upset that you feel upset or that you feel depressed about this. Because it just--
我觉得你感到沮丧或者为这件事感到抑郁让我很难过。因为这只是——
I know it's just a game.
我知道这只是场比赛。
It's not that it's just a game. It's just that it's so long ago and that like, yes, it's sad--
并不是说这只是场比赛。只是它过去太久了，就像，是的，这很伤感——
Oh, believe me. In my life, I'm a very blessed and happy man.
哦，相信我。在我的人生中，我是一个非常受祝福且快乐的人。
Well, that's it, though. That's exactly it. It just feels like this is such an insignificant thing to all of the great shit that you have going on in your life.
好吧，这就是重点，虽然。这就是完全的重点。这感觉就像相对于你生活中发生的所有伟大的事情，这是一个微不足道的事情。
Watch the language.
注意语言。
Sorry.
抱歉。
My dad did point out one positive thing in the video that I couldn't have noticed.
我爸爸确实在视频里指出了我没注意到的一个积极点。
You know what I said to my coach?
你知道我对教练说了什么吗？
What did you say?
你说了什么？
I'm sorry, sir.
我说，对不起，先生。
What were you sorry for?
你对什么道歉？
Losing the game. Now I gotta go. I never told anybody what I said to my coach.
输掉比赛。好了，我得走了。我从没告诉过任何人我对教练说了什么。
What did he say back?
他回了什么？
No, you played your ass off.
不，你拼尽全力了。
At this point, we've been talking for close to an hour. And I realized what I'm doing isn't working. I've been keeping things positive, trying to make my dad see something else-- sugar coating it. And you know what I hate? I hate when people sugar coat things.
这时候，我们已经聊了快一个小时了。我意识到我在做的事没起作用。我一直保持积极，试图让我爸爸看到别的东西——粉饰它。你知道我讨厌什么吗？我讨厌人们粉饰事情。
The truth was, he was right. He didn't play well. That dunk-- he really did pass the ball over the rim, instead of just dropping it in. After that, he only scored three points. He played exactly the way he told me not to play for most of my basketball career, hanging out around the basket, hands down. He missed easy put backs. He did rebound well, but without him as a threat offensively, his team suffered.
事实是，他是对的。他没打好。那次扣篮——他确实把球传过了篮圈，而不是直接投进。那之后，他只得了三分。他在我大部分篮球生涯中扮演了他告诉我不该扮演的角色，在篮筐周围闲逛，垂手。他投失了简单的补篮。他确实抢篮板不错，但没有他作为进攻威胁，他的球队遭受了打击。
I think he's absolutely right. If he'd played better, they would have won. Maybe what he needed wasn't to see himself differently. What he needed was for someone to see him just the way he is.
我认为他绝对是对的。如果他打得更好，他们就会赢。也许他需要的不是以不同的方式看待自己。他需要的是有人能像他现在的样子看待他。
I mean, to be frank, it was not a great game for you.
我的意思是，坦白说，那场比赛你打得并不好。
It wasn't a great-- it was a horrible game for me.
那不是一场好——那对我来说是一场可怕的比赛。
But I wanted you to also see yourself play basketball. And I think I was hoping that it would be different than you imagined.
但我也想让你看看自己打篮球。我想我当时是希望它会和你想象的不同。
Why would you think that?
为什么你会那样想？
Because I always imagined that I played like shit. [LAUGHS] And I like to think I don't look that bad on tape.
因为我总是想象我打得像屎一样。[笑] 我喜欢认为我在录像带里看起来没那么糟。
Well, you see?
好吧，你看到了吗？
We chatted a little longer, my dad looking drained-- I think a little sad. It was late, and the Raptors were about to play the Bucks. So I left my dad to watch his game. I spent the evening pretending to read, but really, I was worried about what I just did. The next morning, my dad told me he had something he wanted to say.
我们聊了一会儿，我爸爸看起来精疲力尽——我想有点伤心。天晚了，猛龙队正要打雄鹿队。所以我留我爸爸看他的比赛。我花了一晚上假装读书，但实际上，我担心我刚做的事。第二天早上，我爸爸告诉我他有话要说。
You know, I actually felt a sense of relief after watching the game with you. I don't think I would've watched it, to tell you the truth. So getting through that with someone that you care and for them to sit there, and watch, and just be brutally honest, like you said, that I played like shit-- excuse my language. But those things are important.
你知道，和你一起看比赛后，我其实感到了一种解脱感。说实话，我不认为我会看它。所以和一个你在乎的人经历那个过程，让他们坐在那里，看着，并且就像你说的 brutally 诚实，我打得像屎一样——请原谅我的语言。但那些事情很重要。
And that's what I wanted, to talk to my dad about the important things. And since I started this conversation, we've been doing that more and more. We've talked about his childhood in Mississippi, about his health, like how dialysis is so depleting, and about his own parents and how he sees them.
而那正是我想做的，和我的爸爸谈谈重要的事情。自从我开始这个对话，我们一直在做这件事。我们聊了他的童年、关于他的健康，就像透析是多么消耗体力，还有关于他的父母，以及他如何看待他们。
Our conversations are not always this deep. But you know what they're not always about? They're not always about basketball.
我们的对话并不总是这么深刻。但你知道它们不总是什么吗？它们并不总是在谈论篮球。
Emanuele Berry is one of the producers of our show. A version of this story appeared on The Nod, a podcast that tells stories about black culture that you won't hear anywhere else. Like, LeVar Burton discussing the love life of black Star Trek characters. You can find The Nod wherever you get your podcasts.
埃马努埃莱·贝里是我们节目的制作人之一。这个故事的一个版本出现在《The Nod》上，这是一个讲述你在其他地方听不到的黑人文化故事的播客。比如，勒瓦尔·伯顿讨论《星际迷航》中黑人角色的爱情生活。你可以在任何你获取播客的地方找到《The Nod》。
Our program was produced today by Lina Misitzis and Nadia Reiman. Our staff includes Bim Adewunmi, Elna Baker, Emanuele Berry, Ben Calhoun, Zoe Chace, Dana Chivvis, Aviva DeKornfeld, Neil Drumming, [? Hillary ?] [? Elkins, ?] [? Damien ?] [? Grave, ?] [? Michelle ?] [? Harris, ?] Seth Lind, Miki Meek, Stowe Nelson, [? Katherine ?] [? Raimondo, ?] Robyn Semien, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, and Nancy Updike. Our managing editor is Diane Wu. Executive editor, David Kestenbaum.
我们的节目今天由Lina Misitzis和Nadia Reiman制作。我们的员工包括Bim Adewunmi、Elna Baker、Emanuele Berry、Ben Calhoun、Zoe Chace、Dana Chivvis、Aviva DeKornfeld、Neil Drumming、[? Hillary ?] [? Elkins, ?] [? Damien ?] [? Grave, ?] [? Michelle ?] [? Harris, ?] Seth Lind、Miki Meek、Stowe Nelson, [? Katherine ?] [? Raimondo, ?] Robyn Semien, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, 和 Nancy Updike。我们的主编是Diane Wu。执行主编David Kestenbaum。
Special thanks today to Dr. Cindy Cisneros-McGilvery, Jayson Haedrich, Rob Howes, Trevar Cushing, Tyler Rickstrew, Aurelie Hagen, Farley Chase, Eileen Berry, Tony Daniels, Jorge Just, and Sam Greenspan. Our website, ThisAmericanLife.org, where you can stream our archive of over 600 episodes for absolutely free-- ThisAmericanLife.org.
特别感谢今天的Cindy Cisneros-McGilvery博士、Jayson Haedrich、Rob Howes、Trevar Cushing、Tyler Rickstrew、Aurelie Hagen、Farley Chase、Eileen Berry、Tony Daniels、Jorge Just和Sam Greenspan。我们的网站ThisAmericanLife.org，在那里你可以绝对免费流式传输我们超过600集的档案——ThisAmericanLife.org。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to my boss, Ira Glass. So this is weird. I called him to ask him about the show this week. And he was at the beach with his pet donkey. And I'm like, what are you doing? And he's like--
《美国生活》由PRX（公共广播交易所）传送到公共广播电台。一如既往感谢我的老板，艾拉·格拉斯。这太奇怪了。我打电话问他这周的节目。他当时在海滩上，带着他的宠物驴。我问，你在做什么？他说——
Coconut oil on that ass now.
现在给屁股涂点椰子油。
I'm Sean Cole. Ira will be back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是肖恩·科尔。艾拉下周将带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。